I don't know if you're familiar with Ernest Becker work and all the philosophies
around there about the fear of death and how
the fear of our own mortality,
our awareness of our own mortality and it's fear as
in case of Vernice Becker, uh, is, uh,
a significant component in the psychology in the way we humans
develop our understanding of the world.
So what are your thoughts in the
context of religion,
or maybe in the context of your own mind about the role of death in
life? Our fear of death in life.
And are you afraid of death?
We cover everything in this podcast covered.
Wow. Okay. Um,
I Sue happen to have benefited perhaps
from living with an older brother who seemingly had no fear of death
while growing up and he did everything. Okay.
So he was, he climbed mountains. He was a rock climber.
He jumped out of airplanes.
Of course he had to be a Greenbrae and go into the special forces where that
type of thing is a requirement. Right. And so,
because of that,
I did a lot of things outside of my comfort zone and which probably I shouldn't
have done and hope, hope to goodness. My kids don't do them. Yeah. Okay.
Okay. So do you, so I do I fear death. Um, I think about death a lot,
actually. Um, you may not know this about me, but in my field,
I was the head. I was the co-chair of the death panel.
It's called the death panel. There was like,
it's the panel to think about death in religious studies.
Um, and I was at for many years, you've thought about it a bit a bit. Let's see.
I think that people are a little too confident. I think about life in general,
that they're going to kind of live all the time and not die. I happened to,
I mean,
I hate to say it I'm super positive and most people would consider me to be
too happy almost. Right.
And so it's odd then that I spent a lot of time thinking about death,
but I wonder if there's a connection there. Yeah. I'm happy to be alive. Right.
That's kind of what the thinking about death does,
is it makes you appreciate the days that you do have. Yeah. It's a,
it's a weird controversy. I tend to believe that, um,
the fact that this life ends gives each day, um,
a significant amount of meaning. So I don't know, uh,
it seems like an important feature of life.
It's not like a bug as it seems like a feature that it ends,
but it's a strange feature. I wish.
I call the good stuff. You wish it wouldn't. Then we know it's interesting, Lex.
And I do point this out to my students because we cover in a lot of the basic
studies courses I teach, we cover all religions or as many as we can,
like the major religions. And so you take Hinduism for example,
and now this is an ancient religion. Okay.
So you and I are here talking about how we enjoy living in life and things like
that. Well,
the goal of Hinduism is basically never to get reincarnated again is basically
to not live okay. And to get off samskara,
which is the wheel of life and death to escape the whole. Yeah, exactly.
Can think of that. Conditions are so different that you and I,
and my students are happy to be alive, but there, back in the day, you know,
thousands of years ago when they wrote, when they actually didn't write it,
they spoke the Vedas, which were the sacred traditions of India.
They want it off. They didn't want to come back. Life was terrible.
That's what people don't have the adequate understanding of history.
That for the majority of people, life is really hard. Right.
And you and I are, and your audience among the lucky
yeah. That we actually life like life. We want to live
most of the time. Yeah. Most of the time.